-Welcome. Thank you so much.
Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
We have --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have comedy.
We have celebrities.
We have music.
We have a full audience tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, most importantly,
we have air-conditioning.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right -- there's a heat
wave all across the Northeast,
and even weather people
can't hold back
how they feel about it.
-If you haven't been
outside yet, it's gross.
-It feels really sticky.
-It is thick.
-Today's probably gonna be
a two-or-three-T-shirt
type of day.
-It's pretty soupy out there.
-Brandon, I know you like to
call it split-pea soup.
-It's gross.
-Swampy.
-Moist.
-Ugh!
-Wow! Soupy, yeah.
That's also how most people
describe their first
post-pandemic handshake.
They're like,
"Are we doing that?"
Swampy, moist, and eww.
It sounds like
Rudy Giuliani's law firm.
-Hey! Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right --
it was so hot today,
I was sweating more than
Trump's zipper.
That's right -- this weekend,
former president Trump
spoke at North Carolina's
Republican convention,
but all anyone's talking about
is the way his pants looked.
Check out what's going on
with his midsection.
It's like he's wearing a fanny
pack on the inside of his pants.
It's just...
It looks like
he bumped into something,
and his pants
deployed an airbag.
You know what I'm saying?
-God.
-By the way, since when
do pants have gills?
Did you see -- What is that?
How do you even --
How do you have to sit
to get wrinkles like that?
It's like you got to be --
You have to have, like,
your legs on your shoulders
or something.
A lot of people
are saying it looks like
his pants on backwards.
Well, it's already
inspired a new ad.
Watch this.
-At the Men's Wearhouse, we've
always offered the finest suits,
the best tailoring,
and the sharpest styles,
which is why
we're proud to introduce
the Front Butt Collection.
Just zip up the back
and face the day.
You're gonna like the way
your front butt looks.
I guarantee it.
-There you go, yeah.
He guarantees it.
-He guaranteed it.
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, this is exciting.
Jeff Bezos just announced
that, next month,
he'll be flying
aboard his company's
first manned rocket to space.
Yep. Bezos will be
the first person in space
to look down and say,
"I actually can
see my house from here."
Yeah, after
the country reopened,
most people bought a new bathing
suit, maybe some hard seltzer.
This guy buys James Bond
and a ticket to space.
That's right --
Bezos says it's perfectly safe
because he's being packed by
the same people
who ship Amazon boxes.
By the way,
those are the same pouches
Trump uses in his front butt.
-Really?
-Yeah.
[ As Trump ]
Hold on, I can fit --
I think I can
fit two more in there.
Hold on."
Alright, ready. Here we go.
[ Normal voice ]
Bezos will only be in space
for about 11 minutes,
which means, for 11 minutes,
Elon Musk will be like,
"I am finally the richest man on
Earth, Earth, Earth, Earth."
[ Cheers and applause ]
For 11 minutes.
Well, everyone is
still talking about how boring
the fight was last night between
Floyd Mayweather and Logan Paul.
If you missed it,
you can see all the highlights
by Googling
"Men hugging for money."
The result was a draw,
so the only loser
was everyone who paid 50 bucks
to watch a fake fight.
And did you guys see this?
In a recent interview,
candidates running
for mayor of New York City
were asked about their
favorite New York movies.
And Eric Adams -- his answer
caught people's attention.
Check this out.
-"Serpico."
-"Do the Right Thing,"
Spike Lee.
-"Taxi."
"Are you talking to me?"
-Yes.
-That was the name of the movie,
and that's the favorite line.
"Taxi."
"Are you talking to me?"
"Taxi Driver," yes.
[ Cymbal crashes ]
[ Laughter ]
-That's the fastest anyone
has ever won and then
immediately lost my vote.
I was in "Taxi."
-Yeah.
-That should be
your favorite film.
Robert De Niro,
who is on our show tonight,
was in "Taxi Driver."
I was so psyched.
I'm like, "What?!
This guy's awesome."
Listen, whoever is running
for mayor in Boston
better say "Fever Pitch."
That's all I'm saying.
"My favorite is
'Pitch Perfect.'"
Some business news.
I saw that, for
a limited time this summer,
Bud Light is launching
new spiked-seltzer icicles.
Take a look at these things.
Ooh.
Yeah, it's already being
called the easiest way
to accidently get
your toddler drunk.
Well, I don't know
who this is actually for,
but Nathan's is
now selling vegan hot dogs.
-Ew!
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not saying they're bad,
but Joey Chestnut
couldn't finish one.
-Really?
-Yeah.
And, generally speaking,
you're probably not
that health-conscious
if anything in your diet
is in tube form.
I just wanted to say
"tube form."
-Yeah.
-Hey, I saw the that
Royal Caribbean just announced
that they will set sail from
U.S. ports beginning next month,
and vaccines won't be
required for passengers.
-Ooh!
-In related news,
Royal Caribbean
will soon be
quarantining 1,000 people.
You know you messed up
when Carnival
is suddenly the classy
cruise line, you know?
But this is exciting,
'cause if you survive
being unvaccinated
and eating from the buffet,
you will be
declared legally invincible.
Well, listen to this.
Organizers of Philadelphia's
Naked Bike Ride
announced that riders will
still be required to wear masks
at this year's ev...
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-So now it will be even weirder
when you recognize a co- worker.
"Hey, Bill! I mean, uh...
Happy 70th, by the way.
Be careful of
that bike chain, buddy."
[ Imitates clicking ]
I thought there were baseball
cards in the spokes, yeah.
-Oy!
[ Cymbal crashes ]
Tire pump!
-And, finally,
speaking of being naked,
a woman in Florida went viral
after she stripped down
and trashed an
Outback Steakhouse.
The manager was like,
"Hey, what do you think this is?
An Applebee's? Come on."
We have a great show, everyone.